this is a production of Cornell
University
good morning although I wish we had
started doing this soil health roadmap
back in the 1970s I'm really happy that
we're working on it together now I
confess I feel really challenged to talk
about in five minutes the decades of
work that organic farmers have done in
relation to soil health this has been
our top priority and our one orthodoxy
if you have healthy soils soils that are
biologically alive and active you will
have healthy crops and the people on
animals who eat their crops will be
healthy our advice to farmers feed the
soil not the plants far as the Vermont
guidelines organic certification state
the overarching goal to improve and
maintain the long term fertility of
soils I speak today on behalf of the
Northeast organic farming Association of
we work it was founded in 1983 but NOFA
was started in the early seventies as an
interstate northeast organization and
it's the premier statewide organization
growing a strong and healthy organic and
sustainable agriculture movement in New
York State we provide education and
assistance to local organic and
sustainable farms connecting farms and
consumers and then we advocate for
policies that support a sustainable food
and farm system at both the state and
federal level we also have the largest
USDA accredited certification program in
New York and this past year we surpassed
the 1,000 farm mark for certification in
New York
another New York in cooperation with the
other six NOFA chapters in the Northeast
states and also often in cooperation
with maka have been engaged in a
multi-year project to identify the best
practices for building soil health and
increasing carbon by identifying the
farmers who are doing the outstanding
work in carbon farming methods that
restore carbon to the soil and keep it
there for the long term in legal
pathways to carbon neutral agriculture
Peter Lehman leaner and Nathan Rosenberg
defying Carbon Farming as a suite of
climate friendly practices and
strategies designed result in optimal
environmental societal and climate
outcomes so that's what we are trying to
encourage organic farmers to do more of
organic farmers strive for integrated
whole farm plans that's what you have to
do in order to be certified you have to
create a plan with complex interrelated
goals so the nofa's have identified
farmers with outstanding soil health
practices by holding roundtables that
are winter conferences and then once we
identify these farmers we encourage them
to share their practices so it's farmers
learn to hold workshops and feel these
their farms we've done that in New York
State by having these soil health feel
roundtables at the winter conferences
and then having field days at farms in
this photo that we see before you is
from Four Winds farm where we held a
field day in 2016 and they have a
no-till vegetable farm where they also
produce their own compost so the
workshops at our winter conferences
cover the science of soil health and
also a wide range of practices that
build soil carbon
and our annual conferences have taken
things like diversify regenerate healing
the climate healing ourselves with keen
odors like dr. Lanham Fred Magdala Eric
to inspire West Jackson Wendell Berry
Andre you and David Montgomery and his
wife Ann who are our keynote ears last
year the fall 2017 issue of our
interstate publication the natural
farmer focused on climate change and
soil health and that's now archived on
the natural farmer website so you can
access them easily and the NOFA
Massachusetts chapter has taken the lead
in providing resource materials for this
initiative so you can check out their
website NOFA match not word dot slash
carbon and this initiative includes an
unfunded discussion group for farmers a
database of farmer practices a white
paper soil carbon restoration and
biology do the job by Jack ca'tridge and
a traveling program for gardeners
kittredges white paper has now been
translated into 17 languages
north amasses been doing examine aiding
examining the laboratory test for
measuring soil carbon and we found that
they're still really inadequate and also
expensive so instead what we've been
trying to do is to develop a number of
tests adapted from agricultural and
institutions like the NRCS and Cornell
very simple and that farmers and
gardeners can do themselves tests for
soil quality vitality and carbon
sequestration capability and they've
included that the rest procedure is to
run these tests annually on the same
ground and note the changes that occur
since the last time I'm a single test
that seems to be the most the best
measure is to test for water
infiltration and I see that the farmers
who've been doing that also looking at
that themselves that it's a simple thing
that you can do based on the work of
NRCS better water infiltration indicates
more pores or aggregates and that
indicates that there's more soil carbon
and greater soil life so the NOFA
certification program also encourages
prescribed grazing and NOFA New York
together with no further land have
introduced 100% grass bed standards so
this is a side of a farm that has a
chicken tractor and they've integrated
the livestock into their vegetable
production Nova New York has created in
New York org in an action plan and you
can see them on our website and our top
legislative priority for this plan is to
create a healthy soils program in New
York State we want to support research
to increase understanding of soil health
and the connection between soil health
and the nutritional value of food and so
I'm really excited to be here and
work together on theme which is the
legislation that would be most effective
on the federal level you work on the
farm bill and we would like to see
increased funding for soil health
research greater understanding the role
of Agriculture and climate mitigation
technical assistance and conservation
programs through NRCS conservation
reserve program and funding for buffers
to protect organic farms we're a member
of the National Organic Coalition which
advocates for increased funding organic
research through Hawaii I and adding
soil health as a priority NOFA also
supports the Senate farm bill language
there are two farm bill versions that
are out there and we would like to see
the farm the Senate version which will
strengthen conservation programs instead
of cutting out the conservation
stewardship program and increase payment
levels for cover crops resource
conserving crop rotations and management
intensive rotational grazing and we
believe that government and university
programs should spread information
together on climate related practices
and that farmers that do not practice
basic conservation shouldn't be eligible
for you RCS and that's plan thank you
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell edu